c'est qu'ils ont perdu fergie ouais mais
bon il a perdu fergie donc ce soir on a
envie de leur proposer une nouvelle
fergie il y a trois candidates jeu c'est
carole rousseau a beaucoup insisté pour
le faire dira pas moi pas moi vous le
ferez la prochaine fois encore vous
allez procès c'est un torticolis
horrible ah oui c'est vrai bien des
débats s'est rien passé au salon voir ce
que je peux faire
salon de massage allez hop accueillir
tout de suite notre première fergie elle
est magnifique c'est on va démarrer par
va démarrer par et le way is à fergie
ses parts et isabelle fergie
[Applaudissements]
que dalle
tu es tu là
es tu
demain
[Musique]
mal merci
c'est bon quelle bombe la haine de
chauffe futé
là j'ai fait ça avec isabelle personne
ne vient je fais ça la cabine à tout le
monde pense que je vais l'appeler chaude
[Applaudissements]
et franchement j'avais préparé la
chorégraphie non bah ouais ça se voit
[Rires]
c'est de la merde c'est un moteur qui
sera la meilleure serbie bien sûr le
deuxième le deuxième gardien maxime
fergie s'est tout de suite c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi c'est ça c'est très court les
coureurs mes coups mais bon si vous les
mettez à la bourre à moi je préfére
isabelle c'était plus bosser vous
rigolez
ah non nettoyés en fait je cours je
lance tak tak un jeu tourne un peu comme
ça rien de nouveau voyant parce que je
veux inventer
c'est vrai qu'à du boulot bien du boulot
y'a du boulot sera gaulle est elle une
chorégraphe on aime commerce y met tous
on entendit allez vous la troisième
fergie beaucoup misé sur elle je ne vous
le cache pas mais peut-être qu'elle va
nous décevoir
peut-être pas c'est kelly fergie que ces
partis avant
[Applaudissements]
ça
[Musique]
nous comptons en parler sans doute
tout est
[Applaudissements]
nouqué
m
[Applaudissements]
salvat kelly c'est la seule masse qui
donnerait à fergie et qui t'habite à
danser comme dans une bagarre dans c'est
comme ça et franchement tu as bossé toi
si on est fiers de khénifra est appelée
fairy tale ventes étaient dans le rouge
allez chéribourg et statut reste comme
ça non bah non je viens partir parce que
ta cour de cheval après tout non merci
au bâton pour les cours les résultats du
vote utile
la pub mais il sera la meilleure verdi
dont l instant les black eyed peas 3
avec tous jeudi les séries ça est une
émission de fou et bien sûr en direct
acteurs roule sur avec carole rousseau
avec eux toute l'équipe et il ya plein
de choses
alors dites-nous pour qui vous allez
voter vous déjà thomas tabou au pied des
deux roues carole peu loin un parent a
fixé - isabelle nouvelle egypte italie
ces vraies questions par pitié maxime
avoue maïza d'accord vous mis fin
moi aussi visas ils partent à wave ou
qu'elle est bien sûr kelly on voit ce
que on voit ce qu'ils veulent plus
choqué ning et on voit ce qu'on va voir
ce qu'ils font c'est bizarre il y avait
une édition 2009 0 et henman et d'abidal
a pas d'ombré
je vais gagner forcément j'aurais gagné
forcément attendu dans ces pays
[Applaudissements]